welcome back we were we were in the
midst of figuring out the Laplace
transform of sine of eighty when I was
running out of time and so I just you
know why this was this was the this is
the definition of the Laplace transform
of sine of eighty I said that also
equals why this this is going to be
useful for us since we're going to be
doing integration by parts twice so I
did it integration by parts once then
integration by parts twice I said you
know don't worry about the boundaries of
the integral right now let's just worry
about the indefinite integral and then
after we solve for y let's just say Y is
the indefinite version of this then we
can evaluate the boundaries we got to
this point and we made the realization
after doing two integration by parts and
being very careful not to hopefully make
any careless mistakes we fit we realize
wow this is our original Y right if I
put the boundaries here that's that's
the same thing as a Laplace transform of
sine of eighty right that's our original
Y so now and I'll switch colors just to
avoid monotony this is equal to actually
let me just this is why this is equal to
Y right that was our original definition
so let's add a squared over sine squared
Y to both sides of this so this is equal
to y plus I'm just adding this whole
term to both sides of this equation plus
a squared over s squared Y is equal to
so this term is now gone so it's equal
to this stuff and let's see if we can
simplify this so let's see if we can
let's factor out an e to the minus st
actually let's factor out a negative e
to the minus st so it's minus e to the
minus st times
time's side well sign of actually let's
factor out it well let me just write one
over s sign of eighty minus one over s
squared cosine of eighty I really hope I
haven't made any careless mistakes and
so this we can add the coefficient so we
get one plus a squared over s squared
times y but we could that's the same
thing as s squared over s squared plus a
squared over s squared so it's s squared
plus a squared over s squared Y is equal
to e minus e to the minus s T times this
whole thing sine of eighty minus one
over s squared cosine of eighty and now
this right here this is since we're
dealing everything with respect to DT
this is just a constant right so we
could say a constant times the
antiderivative is equal to this this is
as good a time as any to evaluate the
the boundaries right if this had a T
here I would have to somehow get them
get them back on the other side so that
because the T's are involved in
evaluating the boundaries since we're
doing our our definite integral or
improper integral so let's evaluate the
boundaries now and we could have kept
them along with us the whole time right
and just factor it out the this this
term right here but anyway so let's
evaluate this from 0 to infinity and
this should simplify things so the left
hand side of this the right hand side of
this equation when I evaluated at
infinity what is e to the minus infinity
well that is that is 0 we've established
that multiple times and now it
approaches 0 from the negative side
they're still going to be 0 or it
approaches 0 and then that times what
will sign of infinity well sign just
keeps oscillating right between negative
1 and plus 1 and so does cosine right so
this is bounded so this thing is going
to overpower these and if you're curious
you can graph it this kind of forms an
envelope around these oscillations so
the limit as this approaches infinity is
going to be equal to 0-0 and that makes
sense right these are bounded between 0
and negative 1 of these this approaches
0 very quickly so 0 times something
bounded between 1 and negative 1 another
way to view it is the largest value this
could equal is or the is is 1 times
whatever coefficients on it and then
this is going to 0 so it's like 0 times
1 anyway I don't want to focus too much
on that you can play around with that if
you like - this whole thing evaluated at
0 so - what's e to the minus 0
well that is e to the minus 0 is 1 right
that's e to the 0 we have a minus 1 so
it becomes plus 1 times now sine of 0 is
0 minus 1 over s squared cosine of 0 so
what is what is 1 over cosine let's see
1 a cosine of 0 is 1 so we have minus 1
over s squared minus 1 over s squared
times 1 so that is equal to that is
equal to minus 1 over s squared and I
think I made a mistake because I
shouldn't be having a negative number
here so let's let's let's backtrack and
let's see where that mistake might maybe
this isn't a negative number
let's see infinity right this whole
thing is 0 - let's see when when you put
0 here this becomes a minus 1 yeah I'm
getting a let me see where am I so
either this is a plus or this is a plus
let's see where I made my mistake
e to the minus s T oh I see where my
mistake is right up here where I
factored out an e - a - e to the minus s
T right fair enough so that makes this 1
over s sine of 80 but I 5 factor out a
minus e to the minus s T this becomes a
plus right it was
- here but I'm factoring out a minus e
to the minus st so that's a plus this is
a plus boy I'm glad that was not too
difficult to find so then this becomes a
plus and then this becomes plus thank
God it would have been sad if I wasted
two videos and I ended up with a
careless negative number anyway so now
we have s squared plus a squared over s
squared times y is equal to this
multiplied both sides times s squared
over s squared plus a squared divide
both sides by this and we get Y is equal
to 1 over s squared 1 over s squared and
actually let me make sure that that is
right it's 1 over s squared right y is
equal to 1 over s squared times s
squared over s squared plus a squared
and then these cancel out and let me
make sure that I haven't made another
careless mistake cuz I'm a feeling I
have I have a feeling I have yep there I
see the careless mistake and it was all
in this term it was all in this term and
I hope you don't mind my careless
mistakes but I want you to see that you
know I'm doing these things in real time
and and I'm human
in case you haven't realized already
anyway so this I made the same careless
mistake so i factor an e to the minus st
here so it's plus but it was a over s
squared so this is an a that's an a and
so this is an A
and so this is an a and so this is an a
right this was an A and so we're left
with and this is the correct answer a
over s squared plus a squared so I hope
that those careless mistakes didn't
throw you off too much
you know this these things happen when
you do integration by parts twice with a
bunch of variables but anyway now we are
ready to add a significant entry into
our table of Laplace transforms and that
is that the Laplace transform I had an
extra curl there that was unnecessary
let me do it again the Laplace transform
of sine of 80 is equal to a over s
squared plus a squared and that's a
significant entry and maybe a good
exercise for you just to see how fun it
is to do these integration by parts
problems twice is to figure out the
Laplace transform of cosine of eighty
and I'll give you a hint it's s over s
squared over over s squared plus a
squared and it's nice that there's that
symmetry there anyway I'm almost at my
time limit and I'm I'm very tired
working on this video so I'll leave it
there and I'll see you in the next one